With a population over 30 million people,
Peru is the 4th biggest country in Latin America
and one of the richest countries in terms
of natural resources and biodiversity in the
world.
In this vast Andean country we can find, among
many other resources, the biggest silver reserves,
the third biggest zinc and copper reserves,
and the sixth biggest gold reserves in the
world.
In this video, we’ll talk about Peru.
Ikuchita VisualPolitik!
Peru is still a poor country, and there is
still a great deal of development to be done
when it comes to its institutional framework.
But despite this, Peru stands out among its
Latin American neighbours as a positive example
of good reforms.
And some even say that, if this process continues,
we will soon be talking about Peru as a great
Latin American power.
Lima, its capital city, has already a bigger
GDP than Bolivia.
Economic Evolution
Peru has recorded in the last decade the second
biggest growth rate in all of Latin America.
In the same period, its GDP has more than
doubled; the investment rate has gone from
13% of GDP to more than 20%; and the poverty
rate, this is the percentage of people who
can't afford basic things (food, clothes,
education and health care) has dropped from
rates of over 50% in 2000 to 22% today.
Which is less than half.
Not bad at all.
And hey!
Peru is one of the least indebted countries
in Latin America and even worldwide!
Due to a strong determination to use public
funds responsibility, an achievement reached
though the work of the previous governments
of Oyanta Humala, Alan Garcia and Alejandro
Toledo- the public debt has been reduced to
less than 50% since 2000.
And today, it represents little more than
20% of GDP.
But, how did Peru's prosperity begin?
Or better still, how did it reach such political
consensus which maintains stability with the
government's budget while making pro-market
policies?
This is
probably one of the most interesting things
about Peru, and also where it can teach others
a valuable lesson.
Recently, we’ve made a video talking about
Venezuela…
Interestingly Peru’s economical situation
in the 80’s was even worse than Venezuela’s!
So let’s see what happened.
80’s crisis
In the 70s at the beginning of the 80s, the
Peruvian government bet on boosting the economy
through public investment, replacing imports,
and restricting the purchase of foreign products.
To achieve this, they had to borrow money,
which shot up the public debt.
The results were so bad that when the oil
crisis happened in 1979 and their economic
growth slowed down, Peru’s government started
to have so many problems that, in 1983 they
had suspend payments to their debtors.
In other words, they failed to pay their debts
because they ran out of money.
The Peruvian government collapsed!
From that moment things went from bad to worse,
and when Alan Garcia came to power in 1985,
the country was almost a complete disaster.
The government started to intervene on a massive
scale fixing prices, and in the labour market
they reinforced the import replacement policies
limiting the number of products to available
to buy, and setting an average tariff which
reached, an amazing 66%!
The
public deficit went through the roof and the
informal economy became the norm.
So, even though there were more than a hundred
taxes, the State couldn’t manage to collect
them.
And since the government had collapsed and
nobody wanted to lend them money, they were
in a bad position.
So, what did they do?
Well, they started to print more and more
money, transforming the Inti [*pronunciation:
een-tee], - the Peruvian currency, into something
with about the same value as Monopoly money.
As if this were not enough, the narco-traffic
and terrorist actions of groups as Sendero
Luminoso and the MRTA spread out over the
country causing tens of thousands of deaths.
The result?
At the end of the decade the GDP had dropped
by 25%; GDP per capita was similar to 1960’s,
annual inflation exceeded 7,500% and the World
Bank recognised Peru as one of the poorest
countries of the world.
The situation was so grave that the World
Bank estimates, if it hadn’t happened, Peru’s
GDP and purchasing power parity would today
be similar to Italy’s, Spain’s or South
Korea’s.
No more, no less.
In many ways the Peruvian crisis was very
similar to the one which is facing Venezuela
today: a lot of public spending, a lot of
taxes, plenty of printing money, combined
with violence and a drop in commodity prices.
When we released our video about Venezuela’s
crisis many of you asked us what we wiykd
do to solve it.
Well, let’s see what Peru did.
A WAY TO PROSPERITY
In 1990 a strong plan of reforms and economic
stabilization began.
That same plan still practically persists
today.
It passed through these stages:
In order to slow down inflation, the Inti,
the national currency, was replaced with a
new one, the New Sol and the “dollarization”
(the use of US dollars in their economy) was
allowed in practice.
From that moment, monetary stability became
a national priority.
The tax system was changed and simplified,
removing 64 taxes.
The pension system was restructured, taking,
as a model, the Chilean system of capitalisation,
but introducing many improvements.
(We’re actually going to talk in depth about
this controversial topic in a future video).
Further, an ambitious program to attract investments
and privatise public utilities was set into
motion.
Soon, companies such as Aeroperu, Electrolima
and the Peruvian Telephone Company were privatised.
A “trade openness strategy” was approved
which has led to a reduction of the average
tariff from the unbelievable 66%, to figures
close to 1,5%, while at the same time numerous
free trade deals were been signed: including
important ones with the US and European Union.
In 2002 a gradual decentralization of power
started, which resulted in today most of the
public investment spending belonging to regions
and municipalities.
And, finally, probably the most important
point, was their commitment to budgetary stability,
something that every government since has
respected.
Actually, in 1999 a law was approved called
the ‘Fiscal Transparency and Prudence Law’
which restricts the discretionary power of
the governments to spend more than they receive
- including corrective elements for public
deficit situations.
Many experts assert that this is the most
important law in the history of Peru.
It’s not all roses though, don’t think
that we’ve forgotten Peru’s darkside - the
1990s and Alberto Fujimori’s authoritarianism,
a President that today is in jail serving
a 25 year sentence for crimes against humanity
and corruption.
As you can see, and I’m here talking specially
to our friends from Venezuela, it doesn’t
matter how bad things are.
There’s always a way out.
PERU TODAY AND TOMORROW
So, why is Peru still a poor country today?
As we said at the beginning of this video,
the institutional shortfalls and challenges
that this nation are facing are many.
Among them, we can’t stress enough the high
degree of corruption and legal uncertainty,
something that we can clearly see with the
“Death Squads case” - Where, under Oyanta
Humala's government, from 2011 to 2015, a
group of policemen killed innocent people
for money.
This group included even a general and a major
from Peru's National Police".
Further, the extremely high levels of crime
and the risk that the mining industry could
entail the same rentier problems that today
Chile suffers.
Not to mention the sharp contrast in the living
standards among different regions.
On the 5th June, 2016, the second round of
presidential elections was held where Pedro
Pablo Kuczynski was elected as the new President
of the Republic of Peru.
These elections were the closest in Peru’s
history and Kuczynski beat out his adversary,
Keiko Fujimori, Alberto Fujimori’s daughter,
by little more than 40,000 votes.
The policies announced by Kuczynski include
to keep working on the agenda of pushing competitiveness
and trade openness.
In this regard, he has pledged to reduce tax
to 10% for SMEs (small or medium enterprises),
as well as to battle against bureaucracy,
remove unnecessary regulations; and to pursue
regional economic integrations, similar to
the TPP or the RCEP led by China.
If Kuczynski gets to remain at the helm and
fight all the problems which affect Peru,
despite his relative political weakness in
a not very friendly congress, I’m sure that
the growth of this Andean nation will continue,
and will remain the leader for growth in Latin
America.
And maybe, in a few years, Peru (a young nation
with a median age of barely 27) may emulate
the development of the Asian Dragons and get
transformed into a major global power.
So, what do you think?
Will Peru manage to leave poverty behind and
turn into an economic powerhouse?
Is Kuczynski the ideal person to achieve this?
Feel free to leave your opinion in the comments
and subscribe to the channel by clicking here
to receive our new videos.
See you!
Or as we’d say in quechua, TUPANAMCHISKAMA